e aí galera existe um campeonato bom
vocês meu quarto é igualzinho e gosta de
passar porque porque eu não mexo no meu
quarto não sei porque estou gravando no
mesmo dia eu sou muito bom mesmo gente
estou preocupado estou um pouco
preocupado com os filhos nas minhas
primas gestão do cérebro sinceramente eu
estou preocupado porque a vida está a
infância está comprometida é sério gente
por favor me perdoe pelo que eu vou
falar agora eu não quero ofender ninguém
mais a mãe de hoje estão criando cada
baquinho então regam babá tinha para
onde receberá um babaca o menino hoje
num suja o pé de areia no chão é para me
proteger do leste black to black ops
pirozzi é proteger a leptospirose mas
não pode privar o menino de brincar não
pode privar alguém de fazer as coisas de
criança tinha medo era criança eu
brincava de verdade ou consequência a
liberdade consequências etapa de
crianças roda o litro o que parar
perguntou se fosse verdade a
conseqüência é verdade é verdade e doía
paulinho já dá um beijo na boca e keita
vou dizer um frio na barriga aquela
coisa boa quando escolheu desafio
verdade desafio desafio olha eu desafio
a bolinha a dar um beijo na boca do
beijing eu não perdi minha escola não
dente beija veja amanhã de são paulo
sobe tanquinho uma chapa com o risco
hoje em dia as crianças tudo anda pai
hoje estou querendo comprar mais novos
jogos na playstation
enquanto o papai já 200 salvar esse jogo
de carro não quero jogo de lógica para
que eu possa limpar minha talvez
exercitar mídia hoje em dia se jogar
verdade ou consequência mas na hora que
você conhece hoje eu vou escolher
verdade porque eu não vou escolher
consequência porque é uma sequência é
uma boa sequência que vem do eda pessoas
eu escolhi conseqüência eu posso
vamos fazer uma coisa que minha mãe não
vai mais vai bater minha mãe não vai
bloquear mundo estejam mim tá tudo kaká
frescurinha ter me conhecia gente é o
menino brincar a mulher a criança
brincar do bege ou seja aplicado do vec
o banco é o seguinte uma pessoa tinha
uma lata e tinha lá em casa ficar com um
pau e outra pessoa fica com o palco
principal ea rebateu ea bola pega pegar
qualquer drive que tivesse bem da rua e
para rebater a bola onde a criança para
mim que no pau de céus mínimo três anos
de idade bateu o chelsea não brinca mais
negócio é não brincar do bege gente joga
bola e bateu na lata do time jogar bola
e bate joga com por jogar aqui bater de
pé e rebate a bola ea bola é longe a
pessoa tinha que correr enquanto eu
corria você ea ficar na lata e táctica
na prática na lataria consoante porto
antes isso já ocorria relava caiu no
chão e isso que minha mãe tinha me
proíbe tudo de sujar a minha roupa eu
fazer senão me lembra muito bicho solto
radical era bem pouquinho de calma uma
criança de hoje a fumar de cautela faz é
levantar saltar quando videogame e tomar
água a decat a alegria era chegar na
minha casa e assistir cavaleiros onde eu
adorava fazer se o dinheiro não chegar
nunca assisti a camisa que estava
realizado hoje domina a assistir ao
desenho mais pai que existe no mundo
porque chegar vai ter o que mexe mexe lá
fora do méxico de onde extrai o monstro
este ano estamos aqui hoje de inventar
outro max steel que o méxico eo viaduto
para desviar net remarketing um campeão
um time mandando num cabelo porque você
matar o monstro feio eu acho que num a
gente é gente pelo amor de deus que deu
sangue na vida da criança a gente minha
alegria chegar em casa escutei a música
aqui ó
eu gostaria gente achar dilma assistiu
seus carinhosos adorava os seus
carinhosos vai ter gente vai ter os seus
carinhosos era 10 indica olhos curiosos
na hora da venda de gado estava dizendo
minuto a partir daqui para frente dá um
tapa natalina é dois passes que exaltem
gente pelo amor de deus salva as
crianças de ser idiota não deixa essa
terceira derrota no botão foi deus que
não tiver um filho ele vai ser uma
pessoa que vai ser tudo de bom dia que
você está assistindo um adolescente hoje
mas quando você tiver um filho sempre
ofereçam pessoa como eu tenho chega me
dá uma coisa mas sim seu filho é uma
pessoa boa pessoa coisa não gostar muito
obrigada a assistir sem ataques em busca
desse vídeo clipe gostei
aqui no youtube se você vir sempre lá no
facebook já sabe que tem que fazer já
expliquei os outros votos no facebook da
artista ajuda tanta gente se inscreve no
canal para o período de novo quer me
seguir no twitter recusou a falar comigo
aqui em baixo a descrição do vídeo
instagram na descrição do vídeo muito
obrigada a assistir sevilha está aqui